- [Voiceover] And as I was like
shitting in this Tupperware
I just felt so close
to my dad, you know?
I was like, oh my God and just
(fart noise)
(techno music)
(applause)
- Here's the show,
it's very simple.
It's just a bunch
of funny people
who are all telling
true stories.
She's a great story teller.
You guys will
absolutely love her.
She has her own one-woman
show called Bad Bride.
Ladies and gentleman, Ms.
Giulia Rozzi everybody.
Let her hear it.
(applause)
- So I live in New York
and New York is gross and
beautiful as we all know
and I've experienced a lot
of disgusting things there
such as one time I was
eating pizza in a pizzeria,
and as I was eating pizza
one of the ceiling
tiles opened up
and a rat fell out of
the ceiling, a living rat
and it wasn't one of
those like cute rats
with like the hat and the sass
from Muppets Take
Manhattan, you know?
Because one of those rats,
I would have been like
all right cool rat, you know?
But it was just a nasty
like Syphilis-filled rat
and it (thunk)
fell on the ground
20 pounds, whatever it
was, like an infant.
It fell and I, just
without even thinking,
instinctually I just
jumped on the table
and then I threw my pizza at it
'cuz that's what you
do in an animal attack
you give it food immediately.
And then someone opened the door
to walk into the
pizzeria and the rat
was like such a city
rat, it ran right out.
It was like, "I have a meeting
on the upper westside,"
you know it was just
like, wearing like
you know Manolo Blahniks
and drinking a
martini or whatever.
I said to the guy
behind the counter,
I go hey a rat just
fell out of the ceiling.
And he goes, "That's
New York, for you."
I was like, what?
Why do we live here?
But it's wonderful.
So that happens and then
the other thing that happens
when you live there for awhile
not only do you get used
to disgusting things,
but you yourself kinda
become a little grosser
than most people in other
parts of the country.
Like I've done some gross things
and the grossest
thing I've ever done
was about eight years ago and
my toilet was broken
in my apartment.
And my boyfriend at
the time went out
to go get a plunger
and I couldn't wait
because I'd already
had coffee and
I shat in a Tupperware.
(laughter)
A brand new Tupperware,
hadn't been used before
and as I was shitting
over the Tupperware,
I was standing
over the tub just--
I had drank the night
before, it was just a mess.
(laughter)
Yeah, you should.
Everyone should hate me.
So I am shitting
in this Tupperware
feeling so ashamed and
all I could think about
was my parents were
immigrants from Italy
and how my dad would
always tell the story
of how when he immigrated
here he was on a boat
and he traveled all these miles
and he had to poop in a bucket.
And as I was like shitting
in this Tupperware
I just felt so close
to my dad, you know?
I was like oh my God and just
(fart noise)
And then when I
realized what I had done
like after, and it was
like a quart-sized,
it was like a big container, I
put it in multiple trash
bags to hide my shame,
and then I shoved it in
the garbage downstairs,
and I buried it in there deep
'cuz I was terrified
that a homeless person
was gonna walk by and be
like, "cake," you know
and just, so I hid it in there,
and then I went back upstairs
and I sat on the couch
just in silence and like
my boyfriend walks in--
again five minutes,
this all happened--
with a plunger and
just sees my face,
sees like the guilty puppy look,
and is like, "What did you do?"
And I was like (groans).
So, I am guilty of
disgusting things,
but nothing, nothing
could have prepared me
for what happened
to me two years ago.
When I was getting
off the subway,
and I was walking up the steps,
and I just innocently
grabbed onto the railing
and I felt something
wet on my hand.
And I looked down
and it was brown.
(laughter)
And it was clumpy brown
and I thought to myself
Oh this is just chocolate.
Someone was eating a candy bar
and just smeared it right?
That can't be what
I thought it was.
And I didn't wanna react, right?
I didn't wanna like smell
my hand right then and there
and confirm or deny
what was going on.
Instead, what I wanted
to do is I wanted
to get out of the subway station
and I wanted to
get to a bathroom
where I could wash my
hand and scrub my hand
and cut off my
fucking hand, right?
(laughter)
That's what I wanted to do.
So instead of ...
so I kinda walked
out of the subway station
like carrying an imaginary
tray of drinks, right?
Just doing this.
But the smell had
a mind of its own.
The smell was like,
"Ah naw bitch,
you're gonna smell me now."
(laughter)
It sort of, like do you
remember in cartoons
when a smell would
personify into sort of like
smoke, like a sexy
lady smoky hand?
It was like (hums)
Shit. It was shit!
I mentioned I was in a
subway station, right?
And when it, the smell, hit me
I just sort of fell
like Nancy Kerrigan
like, "Whyyyy? Why?"
New York had just given me
the most disgusting
high five in the world
is what had just happened.
How on the railing?
(sputters)
How does that happen?
Either somebody
took off their pants
and slid down the
railing, right?
(laughter)
Or somebody had
diarrhea and they
were doing jumping
jacks on the platform.
I don't know which one it was,
all I know is it was
on my fucking hand.
I get out of the subway station
and I'm kinda like
walking like this,
and people are like
dodging my hand,
and I'm like it's not mine,
like I was just freaking out.
(laughter)
And it's just there and
so I get to a bathroom
and I wash my hands
like 100 times,
I put hand sanitizer,
I just cleaned,
baptizing myself
in hand sanitizer.
I'm feeling slightly
better as one can
when they have to
amputate their fingers
and then I did what I always do
when anything happens to you:
I immediately went on Facebook
when I got home, right?
And I just sort of
casually posted like
oh my God, got shit on my
hand on the subway today.
(laughter)
Very casual, it was like an
off-hours, like four p.m.
You know like, I didn't think
anyone was going to
see it, no big deal.
I gotta say, if you ever want
to get a lot of validation
and attention, write
that you got shit
on your hand on the subway.
The love and support
that I got that day
from my fake internet community,
It was-- it melts my
heart to this day--
it was like, people
were just freaking out,
like guys I had hooked up
with who never texted me back
were like, "Are you
okay?" You know?
Like all the cool
kids from high school
were like, "We should've
invited you to our party."
People felt so bad--and
like this is the thing,
I didn't even think it was
a sympathy status, right?
Like I didn't think
that I was seeking--
'cuz I hate sympathy statuses.
Side note: anyone who posts
one of those vague like,
"Hey guys, having
a really hard day.
Not gonna tell you
what it is, but
thoughts and prayers
would be appreciated."
It's like, fuck you okay?
(laughter)
No, you do not get my
thoughts and prayers
unless I get specifics,
you pathetic asshole.
No, okay?
I had to get shit on my hand
to get over 100 likes, right?
I had to work really
hard for all those likes.
So, I'm feeling better because
people are giving me attention
as that always feels good,
and I'm feeling better,
and then this one woman writes,
"As a mom..." and I
was like (groans).
What? What, Facebook Mom?
What, lady who I don't even
know what you look like
'cuz all of your photos
are of this baby.
Who am I mad at right now?
An adult or a baby with
a sailor hat on, okay?
What do you have to say?
All you do is talk
about being a mom.
What do you want to say?
She's like, "Um, as a mom,
I don't really see
what the big deal is.
I mean, every time
I change my baby,
I get poop all over my hand."
Everybody in the world agrees
that is not the
same thing, right?
We all are in
agreement, not the same.
Adorable baby poop from a
baby that you made: sweet.
Shit hand from stranger:
kill yourself.
Throw yourself on
the tracks and kill--
not the same, like when you have
a baby, right, like you
give her to the baby,
you go change the baby,
you go in changing a baby
being like you know today I
might get poop on my hand.
Like you know that is a
casualty of being parent.
Also, if I got
my--if I had a baby,
and I got its poop on my hand,
I'd be like whatever, it's
like my poop you know?
It's got like my
personality, it's like awww
this is just like my poop.
You know, it's like
cute, not the same thing.
More importantly
than all of that,
what is this woman
doing to her baby
that every time she changes it,
she gets shit all over her hand?
It's a baby, not
a puppet like what
(laughter)
are you some--call
the Facebook police.
Like this woman
is doing something
horribly wrong to her baby.
Here's the thing: maybe
she had a point, you know?
Maybe it's not a big deal.
We've all had
accidents, you know?
I shared my accident earlier
except here's the thing:
when I had my accident
I had the human decency
to do it in a Tupperware.
You know, like a goddamn lady.
(laughter)
Thank you.
(applause)
(techno music)